a sea of white tents and housing
containers in the middle of the
Jordanian desert this is the Al's artery
refugee camp home to more than 120,000
people who fled the fighting in Syria
Donal hurry has been living here for
about a year she her husband and their
family left the hermann der AA to escape
fighting between levels and a syrian
government troops the transition has not
been easy but that love never dull we
finally got used to the heat here
actually we didn't have a choice yeah
but we'll stay because at least our
children are safe when they first
arrived the Hariri's lived in a tent
provided by a UN relief agency now
they're a little more comfortable
they've moved into temporary housing
made of corrugated metal and canvas
they've even got their own water supply
but they're still concerned about their
future we'll go back to Syria only after
Assad that disgraceful person is gone he
has taken so many lives my nephew came
from Abu Dhabi to fight for the rebels
and he was killed my brother was
arrested and we still don't know whether
he's alive or dead we haven't heard from
him in 18 months it's my head of years
yeah yeah little day of over 120,000
people packed in 25 square kilometres
and new refugees continue to arrive many
are traumatized by their experiences in
Syria it's a huge amount of work to keep
the refugees fed and housed Germany's
federal agency for technical relief or
thw helped build the camp first they set
up the water supplies now they work to
keep the community toilets and showers
running
viet minh map here you can see that
someone has stolen the faucet and that
broke the pipe that's a common problem
if it can be stolen it will be so the
water pipe is broken and we're trying to
fix it Hunter said so invested on the
Nile not spies there are always problems
when it comes to distributing water
electricity and housing containers
Killian Kleinschmidt is the United
Nations official who's responsible for
that stage of the program yet if I'm a
year trick I'm every family gets one of
these containers if it's a big family
they get a tent too we try to provide
each family with one of these housing
containers won't contain under the
comments also study the cramped
conditions the stress and the
uncertainty take their toll there have
been demonstrations in the camp yeah
mazza my kids attend sometime yesterday
another car was damaged people come
stones here at the distribution point
there are new problems every day we just
have to deal with them how about a
missing a head boys right nearby someone
is stealing electricity gangs and
marketeers sell it for outrageous prices
and black market has already taken shape
was I named amit nervous not what's
really nerve-racking is when business
people start making so much money off it
it's just not funny anymore this is then
there's only middle stages
a small barber shop offers haircuts for
one euro it's a small price to pay for a
bit of dignity even with all the dirt
grime heat and water shortages the young
men still want to look decent being a
refugee can come as a profound shock but
when there's only dirt and Chuck holes
here the only way we can put up with it
is to keep busy but it feels like you're
being buried alive it would actually be
better to go back to Syria and die than
to stay here hey love I just want to
hear that this regime is gone once and
for all whatever comes afterward it
won't be a problem I just want all this
to be over she's got miss Knox awesome
in the hall below what no one here can
say how long they'll be in Al's Atari
all they can do is get by from one day
to the next but a few have reached the
end of their patients every evening
buses carry hundreds of refugees from
the camp back to Jordan's border with
Syria they're returning voluntarily to
an uncertain fate in a war-torn country
about an hour's drive from Al's artery
along the road to Baghdad the next
refugee camp is being set up it's being
built to accommodate an estimated
120,000 people hardly anyone here still
believes that the civil war in Syria
will end quickly